the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we ended last time kind of without
really a resolution in the sense that we
were looked at this example of these
vendors in in India and the Philippines
and these vendors were somehow they
seemed to be unable to save their their
way out of something that seems
extremely costly to keep bearing they
had they were paying 5% a day and even
when they were given even when somebody
paid down the entire debt so that they
didn't have to borrow anymore they
slipped back into debt within about
three weeks so there was a sense in
which the they were this was a you know
these these people seem to have find it
difficult to stay out of out of debt and
in particular to hold on to their
savings so here's another experiment
which sort of brings out some more of it
it's in Busia Kenya I had a word missing
a letter missing there so the way it
started is that this is by the
experiment is by Esther Duflo
Michael Kramer and John Robinson what
they had done was they started by
actually giving farmers some fertilizer
one of the enduring kind of puzzles in
agricultural economics is why farmers in
Africa don't use more fertilizer given
that fertilizer is something that
basically
makes money for people so why don't they
use fertilizer and their various
possible answers we'll talk about those
but this was to demonstrate that it day
it really does seem to work you could
debate the basic they started by what
they started by doing is making sure
that it's true that it works so what
they did was they had people give
farmers fertilizer and told them you
know this is your plot just go ahead and
use fertilizer and they give them free
fertilizer so they took a bunch of plots
and give them free fertilizer so very
simple we give people free fertilizer
they do use it not surprisingly maybe
especially if you make sure they can't
sell it and they do use it when they use
it they get their incomes go up by so
twenty twenty twenty seven percent and
that the incomes go up by twenty seven
percent which is a hundred percent
increase analyzed so that's like three
months three months if you had put in
them you bought the fertilizer you let
it in the ground you waited waited for
three months you would get twenty seven
percent more back so they were pretty
convinced that fertilizer was a very
useful thing to use and this they did it
many times so it varies fertilizer is in
fact not predictable sometimes it works
better than others but the the range of
these returns where you never got less
than
80% I think basically on your money and
that's a very good investment if you go
you get eighty percent on your money
sometimes you get five hundred percent
but even if you got a eighty percent on
your money there would be a good
investment so question is why didn't
they do it so this is a I mean the
reason so their various theories
obviously of why people don't do it one
is that they don't know about it
that seems implausible partly because
fertilizer is not it's not a new
technology has been around for a very
long time and second because take those
farmers who had the who had given free
fertilizer they used it they got 100%
return and all eyes return go back to
these people at the end of the year
I even for at the beginning of next
season and asked them do you want to use
fertilizer 98% said yes of course we
want to use fertilizer only 37% actually
use it so these are people who clearly
know fertilizer works because they did
it it worked when they have no there's
no two ways about the fact that they
know know it because in the fertilizer
they had used it they saw the results
the soit's working why why didn't the
farmers who had seen that the pair of
fertilizer generates these massive
returns not go back to using fertilizer
yeah
okay so that's that sort of media so
let's before we come there lets rule out
some other explanations so one other
explanation is is credit constraint so
they you know we already discuss it's
hard for the poor to borrow interest
rates are very high that would be a good
explanation
if fertiliser were indivisible so if you
had to use a certain minimum amount to
get make money but fertiliser is
extremely divisible you couldn't buy it
in like you could buy buy 500 grams of
it put it on a small plot and we'll get
more money you make more money on that
small plot if you had you bought 2 kilos
you make more money on a bigger plot if
you've got 10 kilos you were even more
so the question is why don't don't
people use fertilizers you know if they
have less money why don't they use it on
a smaller plot so it doesn't quite it's
not enough to say that they don't have
money because money just said you know
if you have less money you can use it on
less less land the main point is that
wherever you use it you make money so
even if you will use it on you know if
you using a smaller plot the output on
that plot would still go up by a lot and
the returns would be a hundred percent a
year on the money you put it yeah
where
but it's I guess that might be right but
it's sort of in the end it's why aren't
they thinking look it's it's hundred
Kenyan shillings now I'm gonna get two
hundred in three months if it's 100
shillings and that's very little as a
dollar and a bit it's still you get
twice as much so why is it wired people
thinking in proportions why aren't they
thinking that twice as much as a lot
more yeah
not in Kenya actually I mean fertilizer
is it's true that it will be more useful
but mostly even Kenya has especially
this this is the what they call the the
short rain season most of agriculture in
the shorter in season is rain fed so I
think people people don't but it's true
that actually fertilizer would reduce
risk but you know there isn't much risk
even when the rains are not great you
still make money if you ask farmers they
give you they do tell you the answer
that they don't have any money so there
their answer is we don't have any money
it's you know it's exactly what you said
which is that they don't have money
where how will we buy fertilizer the
fact is that they as you'll see in a
minute they do have money especially
when they when they harvest you know
farming is a cyclical business right you
you make money at some point you you
plant you wait for three months your
crops come out you sell your crops you
get money then you wait for a while you
buy some seeds you plant again so it's
kind of a cycle so if you think of the
big point when they have sold the crops
they certainly at that point certainly
do have money it's not true that they
don't and we'll see in a minute evidence
that they do have money and in
particular they they seem to I mean even
if they can't save all of it because
they need to spend you know eat most of
it they could have saved a little bit of
it so so they could have saved the money
alternately they could just buy
fertilizer then when they have the money
fertilizer is very durable you just buy
fertilizer you put it in a key keep it
in a bag it will stay for three months
it's not that you need to buy fertilizer
on the day when you need to go farming
you could have bought further fertilizer
of time we and kept it in your home so
there's no war so we'll see that they do
have money at some point and when they
do have money they don't necessarily buy
fertilizer with it so this is in fact
they did a small survey and they asked
did you buy fertilizer when you had whoa
at harvest time when you had money the
answer is no almost no one did that so
if you look at the population about you
know thirty percent of them use
fertilizer at any point of time but of
that thirty percent only over three
percent had bought it early when they
had money most of them bought it at the
point of planting so they're either
managed to save or they're borrowed but
in any case they had to remove Skype
yeah
so what is true is that so basically no
one buys fertilizer early even though
you if you think that it's a it's a
problem to you know maybe you don't have
money F at harvest time at a planting
time then you should just buy it early
so here's here's a nice experiment which
is sort of or exactly trying to figure
out what's going on here so what they
did was they went to different farmers
and since some farmers had already had
some experience using fertilizer others
had not they stratified by that so they
basically what does what does it mean to
stratify
right they randomized within the group
of people who had used it before and
within the group of older people who had
not used it before so they had they they
divided up the population and randomized
within each group and then they they
came to the household and offered them
fertilizer and said look you know you
pay for it we will sell it to you and
we'll bring it to you so you don't have
to go to the market to buy it now let's
save that trip saves trouble but it also
so this was done at harvest time and you
know it basically forced them to say it
to make a decision then so you couldn't
say well maybe I'll buy it maybe I won't
Hal wait till till the you know when I
need it it was credible or
all-or-nothing decision where they had
to take a decision right now when they
had money this was the first experiment
then they followed up a second day
experiment where they took another set
of people and they're in the second
experiment they offered people an
additional choice they said you we will
you can either you you can choose when
you will get will come to sell you
fertilizer you can ask either ask us to
come
this was done before harvest so they
didn't have any money at that time
so they said you you can either buy tell
us and we'll come right after harvest or
will come when you plant just tell us
what to do so in the first experiment
they were not given a choice they said
you want it now we'll bring it to you
free you don't have to go collect if not
that's it and then you junior you're on
your own now it's you can either buy it
now or later they were offered a choice
and the other thing that was they did
was other people who were not given any
offer like this when it came to the
actual time of the planting they came to
these people and said do you want to buy
fertilizer we will bring it to you and
then some people they offered free they
offered a 50% discount so they actually
said you know if we give you a discount
will you buy it so these were the
treatments so think of the treatments as
being first treatment all or nothing at
harvest time do you want to buy
fertilizer second treatment before
harvest do you want to buy fertilizer at
harvest or later third treatment do at
hunting time you want to buy fertilizer
too from us if we deliver to you free
that's the experiment
so what they did before we get to the
experiment
suppose people wear what's the
disadvantage of saying that you can only
buy it will offer to you now and but not
later what's the downside on why did
they go to the second treatment today
where they give you a choice or when
Dubai what they'd wonder you're giving
People's Choice
yeah
right exactly so you may so if people I
mean typically we think that buying
things early is a bad idea why because
you're locking up your money and
fertilizers not that easy to sell
whereas you know if you need it if
somebody got sick you had money you
would go you'd be able to you know buy
medicine you now instead you have
fertilizer so why would you lock up
money so in general the the standard
intuition would be that locking up money
is a bad idea not a good idea but in
fact so in the first treatment they were
forced to lock up money the second one
they give them a choice till we take the
first one basically there was a 50% or
so about as I said 30 25 to 30 percent
of them use fertilizer that went up by
11 11 to 14 percentage points so that's
like a 46 to 63 percent increase in
fertilizer use so you get more than 50%
more than 50% increase in fertilizer use
but yet when you just tell people look
we'll bring it to you for free do you
want it at harvest time this did not
change so then what they looked at is
you know this season of course you get
it for you getting it delivered to you
so you buy it it does that have any
persistent effect you saw that there was
a good idea if you start saving saving
money or finding a way to buy it ahead
of time
the answer's no people seem to be when
you offer it to them for free at harvest
time this they buy a substantial number
of them Mike
but if you if you said look last year
you did this look I was good you got
much more output this time why don't you
buy your own
your own just buy it at harvest time we
won't help you but do it you can do it
on your own nobody does it so it's not
the case that people learn from this
experience to buy them buy fertilizer to
use it
harvest time they they they they go back
to not using it basically
so when you give people a choice that's
experiment two you get bigger effects
instead of getting 11 to 14 percentage
points you get 18 percentage points
that's like almost 65 7 75 percent
increase in fertilizer use so so when
you offer it if you give them a choice
then you get more people taking it up so
you get on the other hand if you show up
at harvest time so that this this is not
mainly an effect of offering it took
them you know just bringing it to them
it's not because they're getting free
transportation it's not because they
don't have to go buy it that they're
doing it because you came to them at
planting time and said do you want to
buy it we'll get it to you free that has
no impact so it is not it is if you
bring it to people at how at planting
time free then they don't buy it so it's
not the case that you get the same
effect by just delivering it to the free
at any time if you deliver it to them
free
typically at planting time I'm sorry at
harvest time when they have money you
have to deliver to the free then they
bite if you tell them if you bring it to
them when they are planting and you
offer free delivery that doesn't have
the same impact so it's not that
whenever you offer it to them free they
buy a lot they only buy a lot if you
offer it free when they have money
the 50% discount has a has a does have a
significant effect maybe not
surprisingly on the other hand it's
notice is smaller than just offering
people to get free delivery with no
discount no discount is better than
giving people a discount if you give
them the discount at the right time so
the sorry the free the delivery at the
right time so if I go to you at harvest
time and I say I won't give you discount
what do you want it you get a bigger
effect then if I tell you I'll give you
a 50% discount but I offered that to you
at only at planting time so just those
magnitudes are what's worth looking at
because you know you are you getting
people it's not that people people even
if you offer them a 50% discount you
don't get as big an effect as just
finding the right time to make an offer
without a discount yeah
we just go to the local town and you can
drag it back you bring it on you know
they have all these these three-wheeled
taxis and little trucks in Kenya you put
it in the back of one and you bring it
there is like well no it's a small cost
actually that's the usual now you notice
that there was 18 percentage point
increase that came from a bunch of those
people said look it's free delivery but
we we just wanted delivered at harvest
at at planting time so some people
behaved as if they had no worries about
having the money later and the other
half said bring it to us now so a bunch
of people said bring it to us now so
even though that's the reason why this
one gives you a bigger effect than
forcing people to buy early is because a
bunch of those people actually prefer to
get it late so it's clear that the
economics we described before is is
working for some people but it's also
striking that about half of those people
say no we want it now we want to lock up
our money we want our money to not be
spendable we want it in fertilizer now
so that what's quite striking is that
you know people are willing to lock up
their money even even though it's
so what could be going on so here's sort
of so here's a story that you know seems
to mostly work so these people have
money at harvest time and want
fertilizer but somehow they don't manage
to buy fertilizers so the reason why the
experiment works is that it you know
these these people basically say look we
will buy fertilizer we will Bob so so
what seems to be going on is that people
people as we said ninety-eight percent
of those people who had had plots where
fertilizer was used said they wanted to
buy it again only 37% actually did so at
harvest time it seems most people plan
to use fertilizer and then only a small
fraction of them actually manage to get
there so what seems to happen is that
they don't manage to implement so they
think that they're going to buy
fertilizer but they somehow end up
spending the money before they get to
the fertilizer so one way to think about
what could be happening is that people
say look you know today I really I
really want to buy fertilizer but you
know right now I really like a drink
or I really like to buy some I have a
barbeque so they go to the market they
buy something and they say look but it
doesn't really matter because tomorrow
I'm going to save today let me buy the
let me have a barbecue but tomorrow I'm
definitely going to save so they say
that you so it doesn't really matter
you know the it's going to be in three
months that we're going to plant so even
if I don't save today I'll save tomorrow
so sometimes this is represented by this
formula
these guys are preferences that if
sometimes we buy this formula so the new
function is the utility you get or the
pleasure you get out of eating today or
tomorrow or day after so today is c0
tomorrow SC one day after c2 you know
the day after that is c3 or we go think
of months today is this month c0 this
one C one is next month etc what's
what's important is that you of c1 is x
two numbers both less than one you have
C 2 is multiplied by beta Delta squared
if Delta is less than one Delta squared
is less than 1 but I didn't multiplied
by beta squared Delta squared I
multiplied by beta Delta squared
they are the day after that is
multiplied by beta delta cubed so I
didn't multiply by Delta beta cube Delta
cubed why am i doing that what's what's
the point being made by having that
structure this is sometimes called the
quasi hyperbolic marvel why did I put
that strong
yeah
well specifically the these are constant
so think of them as being numbers like
beta is like a number like maybe Delta
is 0.9 and beta something like point six
that's sort of numbers people often
throw around or over
what does what do this what is this
preference specifically saying
and anything in future as this time
factor beta
further
right but specifically what it's saying
is that today versus tomorrow is very
different from day tomorrow versus day
after or day after versus day after that
it's saying specifically that when I
offer you offer you a choice between
today and tomorrow you want it today but
you you don't care as much about day
after versus day after that so beta and
Delta both both in numbers less than 1
then what what this preference are
exactly saying is that you know the I
would take one today I might I'll give
up to tomorrow to get one today but when
I compare day tomorrow with day after
I'm not going to take one tomorrow
tomorrow instead of to day after so
people are very sure they want things
now but they don't really care about
when they get it if you don't get it now
why is that an interesting set of
preferences well if you believe those
set of preferences then this behavior
seems to start to make sense so what I
really want is I want tomorrow tomorrow
since I don't care about whether I
consume tomorrow or day after
I want tomorrow to do the saving no
today I don't want to save because today
is much more important to me than
tomorrow tomorrow is not that much more
important than day after so if I want
some money for day after the best way to
get there is by eating a lot today
saving a lot tomorrow and then ending up
with the money day after I would rather
do that then eat little today and and
also little tomorrow I would rather save
by binging today and then waiting you
know and then implementing saving
tomorrow the problem is that when you
get around to
what happens if your plan is
I will save more tomorrow a little more
today is say more tomorrow
what's the problem with that plan
tomorrow becomes today one story we go
today you start thinking okay well I
have the same preferences see zero then
becomes tomorrow c0 I want to now I want
to implement the same trend tomorrow so
I want to I want to eat a lot tomorrow
and
get day after to do the saving weather
and Yuki you can keep doing that that's
the problem okay so that's sort of
that's the debt that's the that's the
idea not be new people actually behaves
in such a way so here's a is an
experiment
so this after of color and en asked 1700
subjects in the Philippines the
following questions we asked them first
would you prefer 200 pesos now or 250
pesos later
some people said I'd prefer 250 later in
which case they stopped if they said
that they would prefer 200 now rather
than 250 in a month then they were asked
how about 300
if they said they'll even take 300 then
they were asked how much would it take
to stop you from wanting 200 today
somebody might say 400 I'll take 200
today and 400 in a month okay so there
are people who could say 250 I'll take
in a month
some people say I'll take 300 in a month
some people will say name a number so
how did you see what how it goes then
there even a break they went and wander
around and came back and they were asked
15 minutes later they were asked the
same set of questions but with the one
change which is that instead of us
seeing them about 2 today versus in a
month they were us in 6 months versus in
7 months same thing but notice what
we're doing is exactly this exercise I
really exactly trying to pinpoint
whether or not people have a different
view of today versus tomorrow versus you
know one month later at any other point
of time that's exactly the idea that you
know I'm going to all I mind someone
who's thinks that you know tomorrow it's
going to be do I think that tomorrow
tomorrow it's going to be it really
doesn't matter I can cut back tomorrow
but I really don't want to cut back
today so this is what they found this is
a complicated table but we can go
through it slowly so the way to think
about it is that the each square in a
matrix is how much money would you take
today versus
200 too hard to say how much money in
the future versus 200 today so on the on
on the in the along the vertical
dimension we're increasing the amount of
money in a month from today on the in
the horizontal dimension we're
increasing the amount of money in in a
month from six months
and those are the fraction of people who
make those choices so some people are
just patient those people say you offer
me 200 today
I'll take 250 in a month you offer me
200 in 6 months I'll take 2 to 15 7
months some people say you know offer me
200 200 today I'll take 250 in in a
month or more more than 250 but less
than 300 a month but then they and they
expressed the same preference in in the
future as well but then then the
interesting people are the people who
are who seem to have different
preferences and we see that they're both
kinds of people there are some people
who are there are some people who are so
what is the dark squares what are the
dark squares telling you who are those
people the really dark ones
what what are what are their preferences
don't take less money one month later
require more money
- really dumb deaf ones are the ones who
are saying I'll take less than 250 for
200 in one month but six month to seven
months will take me more than 250 to
compensate so they seem to be the
opposite of the kind of people we were
talking about
yes they seem to be impatient in the
future
but patient in the present there are say
yeah
so if your Wii
sure I mean it makes sense it's just I
don't understand why that's different so
you know it's the same thing it is I I'm
going to get money in the future
investment is just a way to get money in
the future
it's it's just I think it's the same
thing what's not visible what I can tell
you is that those three dark squares
which are people who are patient and
patient in the future in now but
impatient in the future that's about 11
15 percent of the population seem to be
patient now impatient in the future now
the ones who are in the in the kind of
what are called hyperbolic squares
that's about 25% of the population they
are patient the impatient now patient
later right they are the people who are
impatient they're they're saying I'll
take 200 now 300
over 300 later but as a 250 later but in
a month I'll reverse their preferences
I'll take 200 in six months rather than
250 in seven months sorry the other
ground I take 250 in seven months but
200 six months so it's and that's about
25% of the population and then there is
another 17% of the population who are
who are in that other box and there are
people for whom you know about half of
those are actually paid more patient now
than they were in the future and the
other way round so basically what this
shows is that it's not everybody's like
that some people are just very impatient
who are the very impatient people which
which box would they be
those people we don't you're right that
they are the people who are I guess they
are the people who are most impatient
but some of those people are more
impatient now some people are more
impatient in the future who are the most
patient people
which box
yeah so the top top left hand boxes were
the most patient people so basically
what this says is there's about a third
of the population were very patient yeah
no these are a kiss swallow on somebody
not even in the these are not very
significant for daily but really not so
the point that we want to take away from
this is that there are people seem to
vary a lot it's not that this one kind
of people in the world some people have
our patient now an impatient in the
future a lot more people are impatient
now and patient in the future but
there's a whole bunch of people are who
are both impatient now and impatient in
the future and whole bunch of people who
are patient now and patient in the
future so there are all kinds of
different different behaviors in this
table yeah
so here's here's a here's another
experiment it's not not here but out the
mean you let me I think let's let's look
at another one this is actually
interesting I think I have it here or
spoil it for you actually not it's quite
interesting say us this is this one was
done in the US and it's kind of
interesting to see
you okay good did something funny this
is not going to get recorded but it's
it's it's it's this yeah yeah so this is
a very famous experiment from the US
exactly the same kind of question but
now people were asked so this is the
median response so people were asked how
much money would you take in X months
with X is either three months one year
or three years relative to that much
money today
so this is in the US with college
students and then these were Cornell
students if I remember right so you can
see this is the answer is it's
interesting so if I offer you fifteen
fifteen dollars today but says thirty
dollars in three months I mean these
people the median response this is this
is like people who are asked many people
are this question what is them and this
is the answer to the question what's the
median response so if you take the half
of this half the people so for example
for fifteen dollars half the people said
I'll take fifteen thirty less than
thirty half the people said I'll take
more than thirty the median response was
thirty so you can see that basically in
the u.s. in three in three months the
trade-off is basically people want twice
the money that's a yearly discount
factor of two hundred and seventy seven
percent for one year they say sixty
dollars for for three years
they say one hundred dollars now point
is that that number is getting the
relatively you're getting more patient
as you look into the future so it's
today versus the future always but as
you as I make forced you to look further
into the future you become actually more
patient so you don't really and that
sort of the phenomena and I was alluding
to which is that as people really want
it today but the difference between
tomorrow and in one mA one year later is
not that much more
yeah so that's exactly right let's make
the other point that has amounts
increase people look like they're more
patient so if this was a lot of money so
in the u.s. they're going to look
actually more impatient than in the in
the Philippines the Philippines they
were looking much more patient because
these are actually big amounts of money
in the Philippines in the u.s. for those
more amounts of money they look more
impatient these are these imp
so it's when the amounts of money a
bigger people seem to look more patient
that's the bottom line of that the
bottom line of that says that once you
get a $3,000 people really don't want
twice as much they'll take much less
than twice as much to wait three months
so people get much more patient as you
increase the amount of money I think
that's a that's a very kind of
interesting factor I need to go back to
where I was but this this is a so that's
kind of the answer to your question is
that this is actually relatively
relatively people are actually no this
is the wrong need to go back to the PDF
so these are actually they are
relatively patient here because these
are amounts of money which are
relatively large for them if you make
the amount of money smaller people
become less patient not more patient so
in the u.s. they would with these
choices they look more impatient
actually not less less impatient okay so
the question is can this really explain
the fertiliser puzzle so we kind of see
that there are people about a quarter of
the population do behave in this funny
way they want it now and they think in
the future they're going to be very
patient so they want to postpone their
savings they want to say I will consume
now and save later that's a that's a
kind of natural instinct for about a
quarter of the population the problem is
that this requires people to be pretty
naive what do I mean by naive I mean
they need to actually not realize that
this is what they're doing because
otherwise they should be able to say
look but I'll do that tomorrow as well
and they after and the day after that so
I'll never buy fertilizer and I want to
buy fertilizer so if you were
sophisticated and you fully understood
what you were doing what would you do
beautiful yeah you'll buy now you just
buy now you know that you can never
really yeah or do you save now whatever
you need to do you can never post you
know that you'll never win the game by
postponing because you know tomorrow
you'll have the same problem so
basically people who are if you are
sophisticated you would by now or so you
never want to do it so you really need
people to be pretty naive too to be able
to so but in other words sophisticated
people should not react to this program
they would should they would buy in any
case the only advantage this program
offers is that they are getting free
delivery but free delivery as we saw is
not what that much when you give people
just free delivery that doesn't have a
big effect so it's not this is not so in
other words if these guys were really
sophisticated they should not want the
they don't want shouldn't take this
program need this program to get them to
buy fertilizer they would buy it in any
case because they'll realize that this
is what's going on and say look you know
if I if I I can try to fool myself and
say I'm going to buy tomorrow but I'm
not going to buy tomorrow I'm always
going to do the same thing yeah
I'm sure that's also true that there but
but just take this particular experiment
I am NOT I think here the so it must be
I'm sure there are other costs like you
know there is some transportation costs
of finding fertilizer etc but it's it's
hard to imagine that that's that's the
only problem however here's the problem
with saying that they are sophisticated
if people are sophisticated
even not suppose people were
sophisticated then they wouldn't want
the fertilizer the program would not
have an effect because basically they
would buy in any case now suppose
they're not sophisticated so they don't
understand they do this
suppose I come and tell you do you want
to buy now or in the future what would
you say here over say in the future
because why would I want to I I think I
don't realize I'm going to do this so
then I have no reason to say block or
lock up my money I should always ask to
be paid in the future spending in the
future so this sort of you cannot have
them being completely fully
sophisticated in which case the program
would not have an effect because they
are sophisticated they they're never
going to they don't need the program
they'll buy in any case but if you
assume that they were not sophisticated
at all then they wouldn't they would say
look bring it bring it back at her at
20:00 time I'll buy them
why would I lock up my money because I
don't understand that I've had this
problem so you can't so these people
wants me halfway between some being
sophisticated and not being
sophisticated they cannot be either
fully sophisticated they're fully
sophisticated they would not want they
would want to if they're fully
sophisticated they would not need this
program if they were fully
unsophisticated they would not respond
to when you offer them and ask them do
you want to buy it now or later they
would all say later and half of them say
they'll buy they want it now even though
they don't need the fertilizer now so
some of those people must realize that
later they're going to not have the
money so somehow there is some
combination of sophistication and knife
day that's driving this behavior so one
way to look at this question of how
sophisticated is go back to that
experiment that we were talking about
the usher of color ends in what they do
is they offer their subjects are locked
lockbox is just a box where the key is
usually kept with someone else so you
don't have access to the key you can put
money into it it's just a money box and
they were told that you can set your
goal your goal can be either either a
date so I'll break the box or open the
box in at Christmas or it could be an
amount of money I'll open the box once I
have $200 in it so if you look at what
people say most people want
most people want it on a date so like a
huge fraction say I want it on Christmas
my you know wife's birthday my husband's
birthday my son's birthday my child's
graduation or something like that then
some people have a have a amount best
goal they say that I need it for buying
a house so I need this much money but
most people seem to say time-based goals
now out of 1700 people only 200 people
wanted these boxes so not everybody
wanted it
in fact only as like you know one out of
eight roughly wanted about one of these
boxes but among those who did there's a
massive effect of being hyperbolic
hyperbolic are those people who are
patient in the future but impatient now
those are the people who did who really
wanted the locked boxes so that's what
you'd expect you'd expect that somebody
who who's who is fundamentally patient
but is impatient right now is the one
who wants a lock box because they they
do see the value of the of saving their
patient fundamentally but they're
impatient right now in the moment those
are the people who would want a lock box
and that's exactly what you find you
find that the people who want the lock
box tend to be people who are patient in
general in the future or patient but a
less patient right now
they want the lock box just going to
bind their hands is that
so so they seem to know that they're
hyperbolic so a lot of these people seem
to know they're hyperbolic they seem to
realize that they have this problem so
they're not unsophisticated they seem to
be relatively aware of their they're not
at least totally unsophisticated they
seem to have some awareness of the self
control problem the other striking thing
is only women are affected men don't
seem to understand that they're in they
have this problem even if they even
though they do actually
so women seem to understand they have a
problem men men also have the same
problem but they don't seem to
understand it now here's another
experiment last experiment we'll talk
about which which Bree gives a different
take to this man versus women question
so so one one view we've been talking a
lot about this kind of this this
hyperbolic view which says that I am
worried that I won't be able to save an
alternative view of why people don't
save is they feel like I want to save
but I know that I can't because somebody
else will come and take the money away
you know my my husband will spend it or
my brother will come and beg me money
and I have to give it to him or
something so one other reason for not
saving which is related and one reason
why women might be more white want a
lockbox more might not be because just
that they're hyperbolic they might also
worry about the fact that you know their
husbands will just take away the money
and that mind that might explain their
demand for lock boxes that they they
want that keep the money away from the
husband and say that you know we can't
get at the money right now so this is an
experiment with a you know we in a in a
bank the bank is what this one was done
by Simone Shannon who's a PhD student at
MIT
so this is a bank in and people were
basically she invited a bunch of married
couples to the bank and said do you want
to open an account and the accounts they
are she offered had came in three types
I mean everybody's was offered one joint
account for the spouses two spouses one
wife second and one husband's account
the reason why they did that she's
trying to get at this idea that maybe if
I have a joint account with my husband
that's not very good because he can take
out the money if I want to have an
account I want full control of me so
what she's interested in is this
question are people sufficiently aware
of this problem that they're willing to
give up a high return account to have
their own account so the design of the
experiment is one where sometimes
randomly the joint account has the
highest interest rate and your own
account has a very low interest rate and
what she's interested in is whether you
would give up getting a high interest
rate account to get your own account so
the for the whole family will be better
to get a joint account sort of in terms
of returns maybe you can get so the
returns are can vary between 0 to 10%
so you could be getting 10% on the
account instead of 0 but you might
choose 0 because you don't want your
wife or husband to get it get at it
so I'll skip this this is just explains
the point the point is that you know
people got different accounts offered so
some people were offered a joint account
with the interest rate zero a woman's
account a man's account with interest
rate zero but a joint account with
interest rate - so this is sort of just
to understand the experiment you might
be someone who gets the joint account
interest rate could be 10 but the man's
account interest rate could be zero and
the woman's a common interest rate could
be two so this is sort of this so what's
in the squares are the excess interest
rate on on the account you are choosing
so like you know it may be you are you
choose an account which gives you four
percent you could have gotten the best
account you could have got with an
interest rate of ten your the excess
interest rate is negative in that case
you are getting a minus six percent on
the interest so the questioning here the
reason why this experiment is
interesting if you're trying to figure
out do people give up getting lots of
extra money to be to make sure that the
account doesn't have accessed you know
somebody doesn't have access to the
account
so the first thing they did she did was
to figure out this she administered
these questions where they asked them
you know it's kind of like the questions
we were asking how much money would you
give up today to for you know for 290
Kenyan shillings into two in tomorrow so
these are questions basically aim to
measure how impatient people are right
it's would you take 20 today or 200
tomorrow and if you say 20 today you're
very impatient obviously so that's the
kind of question they were asking
she was asking so what you do by using
that what you figured out is who are the
couples who are well matched so if I'm
I'm impatient and my wife is impatient
there's no problem because neither of us
wants to save so I don't have to tie my
husband's hands I don't want to or my
wife's hands because I am you know I
have the same preferences as she does
and therefore I you know if she wants to
spend I also want to spend then there
are couples which are both parties are
patient so if one wants to spend the
other ones to spend and save the other
ones to say then there are basically the
and then there are people who were given
who there are couples which are ill
matched ill matched couples or where one
says I want to save now the other says I
want to spend now to her ill matched
couples now it's the ill matched couples
that are going to choose accounts that
have low returns why if you're well
matched either you don't you know it
really doesn't matter you know whose
name the account is in because we have
the same objectives we want to spend all
both want to spend now we both want to
spend in the future whatever we want to
do we both want to do but if one of the
spouses is patient and the other
you have a problem now they turned out
she wente the hypothesis that she'll
find that only the men are impatient
kantha it was about 50/50 about men and
women are equally likely to be less
patient than their spouse but a lot of
these households were ill matched so a
lot of the households had one spouse who
was very patient and the other spouse
who was very impatient
that's the setting where you imagine
going back to the issue we were raising
maybe people as we said maybe people
don't save because they feel that you
know they can't save they if they try to
save their spouse will just spend it so
if one of the spouses is patient but
there was impatient the impression
spouse kind of has an advantage because
once the money spent is gone the
patient's mustn't keep guarding the
money but the impatience was always here
she has to do is to spend it once it's
spent it's it's gone so in a sense the
impatient spouse always already always
has an advantage so you always fighting
against the impatient spouse the
precious spouse is always trying to save
it
I can't do much about it once the money
is spent whereas the patient spouse is
always can if she saved it through today
she has to save it through tomorrow
sometimes isn't it it's an a kind of an
asymmetric problem so what she's looking
for is what happens to these these
ill-matched couples the couples that are
so this is sort of just to give a sense
of how many are ill Matt yeah Melissa
like so this is this is a graph of
ill-matched couples so there's a you
know some of those zero lot of these are
at zero you can see zero means you have
the same discount factor you're equally
patient but you can see that there are
people who have a difference of minus
0.5 so I want that means that I want it
you know my discount factor is maybe
ninety plus you know 0.9 and my spouse
is 0.4 and look it's basically
symmetrical men and women are not
different it's just one of the spouses
is more impatient than the other and
then what she looks at I'll skip these
and show you the picture so on the
horizontal axis is excess interest rate
how much are you giving up the joint
occur the the when in when the wives
account has let's say the highest
interest rate over the other accounts so
how many what fraction of the people use
the account more so it's you can see
that basically for well matched couples
the share saving in that account is
clearly increasing with the interest
rate if the interest rate is higher you
save more in that account for
ill-matched couples they see no
relationship you don't save more because
the interest account is more rewarding
why because it doesn't matter where it's
more rewarding or not you just don't
want that are the other guy to have
access to that account so ill master a
couples don't react to the interest rate
their their priority is something else
they want their own account doesn't
matter whether that's a low interest
account the well matched couples you see
see this and you can see the same thing
for the joint accounts the joint
accounts again it's the same question
excess interest rate share saving it's
simply the well matched couples as the
interest rate goes up you save more in
that account in the bad limas couples it
doesn't matter interest rate doesn't
matter you're badly matched you choose
the one that you will keep the other guy
out you're not the one that has the
highest interest rate